well Jack we're delighted to see you
here you said you'd never write another
book what made you write this one well I
went around the world the last three and
a half years talking to audiences like
this and listening to questions the
first book was an autobiography is all
about me
and this book is trying to codify some
things that I learned in business in
response to these questions so this book
hopefully is about you
and hopefully about audiences and some
of the things that people have been
challenged by in picking a company to
work for working for a bad boss hey Izzy
the books called winning so what is
winning anyway I think winning is
without question about defining what
your objectives are clearly laying them
out and then going for it with
everything you got and getting there so
one of the things in the book that
you're quite outspoken about is candor
you say let me tell you about the
biggest dirty little secret in business
that in every culture every country in
every society and social class there's
this lack of candor why is that so
important why is it so hard how do you
change that I think you have to build in
an organization it's quite good in a
small start-up where people are all
comfortable with each other they know
what the mission is they understand the
values they reward the values and they
go after it with a passion in a
bureaucracy it tends to get more and
more subjected to pressures from the
side from the top from underneath people
are afraid to speak out and what it does
it slows you down it really puts gum in
the wheat in the gears and it really
doesn't improve the workplace people
aren't being told what what they're
doing well and how they can improve the
evaluation process is on frequent enough
we get into this I'm too kind to
evaluate my team this morning I was in
city in San Jose with a about five 500
executives
startup companies down there and and
some pretty strong tech companies Intel
and others and I asked the four hundred
people how many people thought they had
straightforward relationships in their
company with their peers and with their
associates I didn't get four hands four
hands that's frightening it's sort of
frightening that people are sitting in
an organization and don't feel that
people are laying it on straight and
telling you like it
what was your experience I was lucky to
work for a good company where over time
we really developed this honest feedback
but it wasn't that way when I first
takes real and real leadership and
commitment and you got to reward that
value in the end you get the behaviors
you reward if you reward candor if you
reward straightforward talk you will get
it if you won the other hand don't do
that you'll get close to the best
behavior you've also been outspoken not
only on candor but on differentiation
that part of candor is to be honest with
people about where they stand and you're
noted for this top 20 middle seventy
bottom 10 noting is a kind word tell us
a little bit more about differentiation
and shouldn't we be a little tougher on
student grading perhaps well I think you
I think you probably did a
differentiation school and you recognize
who the top students are and you
recognize where the middle is and you
recognize them on the thing that's crazy
is why is grading and differentiation
okay in the fourth grade through getting
an MBA but it in no way is applicable to
adults it's nuts why you would end up
having this false kindness where you
don't tell people where they stand until
you run into trouble so on my view is
take care of the top-20 and this isn't a
permanent thing it changes all the time
but take that top 20 make them feel
loved how you give them cash give them
rewards in the soul and the wallet do
everything for them that middle seventy
show them what they need to do to get in
the top twenty and that bottom ten tell
them not that they why they basically
should move on and don't do it in a
guillotine job you have a conversation
that goes over a year or so about what
their shortfalls are tell them they're
in the bottom ten don't give them a
raise of any kind of give them two or
three percent that fake raise that keeps
people hanging around cut off that the
salary issue and then ask him to leave
and say left over the next several
months work together to get you in the
right place that's so much better than
these crazy situations companies than in
the valley here they run into trouble
what do they do they going to cut costs
they Bend of a layoff they walk into
people they say look Joe Mary we got to
cut you cut your back we got to take you
out we need to cut cost now and they say
why us and they say well you weren't
that good and then they say but we've
been here 12 years and nobody ever told
us that that's what happens in this
false kindness thing people get misled
and then if you George late in your
career I maintain that not having
differentiation is the cruelest form of
manager the cruelest thing if you have
responsibility if you need people they
should know where they stand as you go
out from school here now with shiny MBAs
when you go work for somebody initially
it's going to be about you you'll be a
leader
you'll be an infantryman tribute
starring something and starting
something up or doing something else but
it'll be about you that day you become a
leader managing five eight ten people it
becomes about them and your future is
tied to them you no longer do the nitty
gritty listen you you build them into
great people and you get a kick out of
that and then you get the benefits of
their success as you go up if you keep
doing what you started doing when you
join the place doing your job your
project rather than building your team
you'll go nowhere in any lay in society
in the book you use candor and
differentiation and a few other things
mission and values and a voice and
dignity as what you call first
principles you just got to have this in
a company to be successful are you
surprised at how few organizations
really have these first principles
shocked I mean it is mission and values
are the most gobbly [ __ ] conversation
pieces in companies I mean a mission
statement ought to be so clear you don't
exactly know where you're going to go to
find it clearly and go after not have
this mission of goodness and all these
other words that can end up like mission
statements make it very clear what you
want to be and then have the values
which I call behaviors values arm issues
were and values are behaviors the
behaviors you want to achieve that
mission and then you measure and reward
as I said in the sole on the wallet
those behaviors and when people don't
exhibit those behaviors and you want
them and you finally have to part
company with people because they didn't
exhibit the behaviors
values you wanted you can't say that
they went home to spend more time with
personal time with the family you've got
to say here's why these people didn't
make it they're good people they're this
and that but they didn't have our values
one of the craziest things you've seen
in corporate America is it's run by
lawyers in some ways where you end up
with integrity by violations and people
say well we had to let so-and-so go they
want to spend more time at home
you gotta say you're going to hang them
publicly for doing bad stuff you've got
to set the tone of your values in your
behavior and you if you're doing it
right you can't be afraid to put it out
there and so I think that you set a
mission you set the behaviors you Albin
you operate in an open candid as you
said takes time build trust transparent
fashion and you give every employee
voice and dignity and you've got a
foundation that means something you
mentioned trust and I know in your
section and your chapter on leadership
and you know one of the key things
leaders have to earn trust nobody gives
it to you you've got to go out and earn
it
do you I'd like to ask you a question
today with compensation and benefits and
stuff do you think it's possible that
executives can be paid so much that it's
really hard for them to win the trust of
their people if they don't think it's
right or fair but it's we have to lay
out clearly what the game is I mean we
have a free market system we have
capitalism it has its flaws there's no
way to come to a perfect answer to every
single what the absolute sows are we
ought to be but it ought to be pretty
transparent people ought to know what
the opportunities are and and the
opportunities to grow I and to get it
and I don't think salary enters into a
lack of trust issue I think if you now
if you get a jerk boss getting too much
money and not it and not building a team
course you'll have it
if you're building a team together
around a common vision you all won't
have it but the whole issue of salary in
severance and all these things is a big
popular subject today and severance in
particular is one that drives everyone
crazy
and the problem with severance and we
just had one with Carly Fiorina here in
this area where she got 22 million
dollars for leaving the problem is not
Kali with the 22 million the problem is
the board at EULA pakad that did not did
not have a succession plan in place so
that when the existing CEO failed and
they threw him out they had to go out
and get somebody and they had offer him
the world to get them if they have a
succession plan that would never most of
these problems come at the front end of
these deals they they they get written
up and beat up on the back end but the
problem came on the on the front end
tako for example you probably all know
about Tyco and Kozlowski and all the
mess that they had they yet they didn't
have a succession plan so they went to
Motorola to get the number two person
there it bring ed green is not going to
go to this tarnished place as disaster
without a package well they had a back a
Brinks truck up to get to get and Breen
to come there now and Brina held out all
the negotiating tools because there was
nothing then when when we had our
success section at GE we had three
contenders at the end jeff ml Bob
Nardelli who went to Home Depot and Jim
McNerney who went to 3m all very capable
all equally capable in many many ways
Jeff got the job Bob goes to Home Depot
they didn't have a succession plan Jim
goes to 3m they didn't have a succession
plan Jim and Bob Jeff got a raise nice
going Jeff congratulations you got a
raise
Jim and Bob the trucks will load the
money on the back of the van because
those two companies didn't have
succession plans so my argument is
succession plans are the answer to
controlling these outrageous severance
--is and these other games where you
don't have these deals bob was here
earlier in the year for a view from the
top and he looked like he was doing well
you say something in the book that
didn't shock me but it may shock a lot
of people and that is you said you know
the chief human resources officer is at
least if not more important than the
chief financial officer and I'll tell
you we're not even close to where we
have to be in this area
most unfortunate Ellison I was in Mexico
giving a talk with my wife Suzie who by
the way wrote this book so I'm just a
mouthpiece in this game we were in
Mexico for 5,000 5,000 HR people were
were there we asked I asked the question
to the audience raise your hand if
you're perceived by the organization to
have a seat at the table equal to the
CFO I didn't get 50 hands now I asked
that question in GE there isn't one HR
person that wouldn't raise their hand
every one of them knows they're equal to
or more important than somebody countin
the numbers I always like to use the
analogy if you were coaching a baseball
team or a football team would you want
to hang around with a team accountant or
they had to play a personnel if you want
to build a great team the accountant
can't do a damn thing for you except
touch to tell you how much my money got
left to offer to Barry Bonds or anybody
else but he can't do much much else the
idea that CEOs hang around with the CFO
the grunt the guy with the green
eyeshades is crazy
the HR person is the person that if if
they're not to most company may make
them the picnics and that plant
newspaper people and the dental plan
fill out the forms but if they use them
right and they build seasoned executives
into the these jobs there will be an
enormous aid to building great teams and
so we we use the line that great HR
executives are really pastor in
listening to people and parents in
discipline kids and so listening there's
an enormous need to have these HR people
be upgraded be the stars of the old oil
organization by not having HR
professionals in many ways but taking
people that are in line jobs that have a
touch-and-go over there the reason why a
job convinced the real reason why HR is
not perceived as a very important
function companies everybody thinks
their HR experts how many of you don't
think you're a people person
ok I mean everyone thinks they are who
who needs a helper is the view it's
wacky you need somebody that's there and
I'd like to see a sarbanes-oxley law
that went in that that would hang check
your companies that on straightforward
with the appraisal process that have the
same rigor around appraising and
evaluating people as they do around the
financial statement if I didn't have my
way then ever sabe Oxley that would
apply to that you human resource process
to put discipline in the company and you
get better teams from it as long as
we're on Finance another thing that goes
on a lot in the finance industry is
merger and acquisition activity and you
have a chapter on MA and among other
things you say that cultural fit is more
important than strategic fit well
certainly equal to or at least as
important and that it but there is no
cultural fit side to an investment bank
that's why that's what I found out
I mean I I'm sure a lot of your going to
the Morgan Stanley's and Goldman Sachs's
and and and some of the great firms on
Wall Street again but you all know
because you're going there it's you you
eat what you kill and it's an
environment around where the measurement
system is really my bonus my bonus my
bonus and it's a whole different pattern
of behavior than it is in a company is
trying to transfer ideas across
businesses as they decided that
boundary-less thinking is moving people
around around the world to build leaders
in northern vigil contributor stars it's
a whole different culture but back to
the the M&H at the bob we spent a lot of
time going over some of the aspects of
in M&A one of the silly things that well
first of all the one one the big big
census deal heat and we're seeing heel
heat right right now money is relatively
inexpensive look at the bidding for MC
i-- i mean it might have been a good
deal in six billion I don't know how
other than to investment banks trying to
measure chillin how it should be a good
deal at nine and a half to ten and and
now I don't know where it's going to
stop but this stuff once you're going to
deal heat all rationality goes so we
talked about the Stig to deadly sins of
mergers and acquisitions first one is
deal t-yong investment bankers like you
will be driving poor dumb CEOs to do
some of the stupidest things in the
world when they get it the deal heat and
and the challenge is to kick you out as
it gets too hot not Stanford in me you
know so and we talk a lot about the
conquerer syndrome where you go in and
you you have all the answers and you
throw out all all the knowledge that was
there because they cut the conquerer
wins we talk about for for the acquired
person the dumbest thing are quiet
people ever do is when somebody by
is the firm they're at they pout about
the deal and they resist let me tell you
if you spend billions of dollars for a
company and you show up to see the new
people and they're just giving you a
sour face and a resistance look people
will will keep positive buy-in people
with average IQ a lot more than they'll
keep resistance with brains it's a crazy
syndrome but it happens all the time the
resistors are not an attractive bunch in
the takeover process you've seen that in
companies you've been involved in so
we've got a chapter here in winning that
deals with all the personal elements
seven deadly sins and they of MMA and in
there in the book you also have a
chapter on a subject that's very much on
the hearts and minds of our students
that is called the right job and you say
a great job can make your life exciting
and give it meaning the wrong job can
drain the life right out of you so how
do we get the great jobs right that's
what people wanted it page 257
we have a grid 5:5 clear-cut things to
think about
one is people when you look for a job be
sure you look for people that will like
you they laugh at the jokes you you
laugh at they think the way you think
they have the same sensibilities if
you're a nerd go hang out with nerds
but don't end up confusing the issue
never have to put put on a persona to be
in the job you pick as far as
opportunities are concerned always go to
a company where there are smarter people
around you then than you where you can
learn where you can grow don't go to a
place where you're going to be the
smartest person in the place it doesn't
do much more for you now I'm office for
startups and entrepreneurs and that may
be right there if you've got the idea
and you've got the vision and you're
going after it and I applaud that
totally but if you're going to a company
that's worthwhile options of the third
then we talked about if you're going to
a company and you're not sure exactly
what's right I would go to account
company that has a brand a brand counts
whether it's Microsoft J&J guu you
picked the company Wells Fargo you
prefer hearing you pick a company that
has a brand because if things aren't
right for you in your first job your
brand will be very important as you look
to the next job and people in the
chemical industry we used to always want
one on hire people from DuPont they
probably weren't any smarter than
anybody else but we thought they were
and the same thing is true of Microsoft
people out here boy I want to get a
Microsoft person and they probably have
a pot full of duds but nevertheless it's
it's a it's a wonderful it's another one
of those chips you have you can ask pom
away when he comes here whether he has a
pot full of done right
no but hat but having options based on
the brand is important the fourth one is
ownership own the company you're going
to don't take a responsibility for the
job you take don't blame it on someone
else my mother wanted me to always live
here I've got a spouse and I can't
travel if you if that's the case make
that deal going in knowing it but don't
then come home and check the dog or
punch the wall because that that's
what's happening and finally work
content be sure the work turns your
crank don't go to the job for an extra
ten bucks of fifteen bucks or whatever
the number is go to the job because the
work turns your crank really turn to one
excites you every day that's what you're
going to look for you can't go to one
because it's well it's a job for now as
I look for another one
if the month the money is good I don't
like to work but I but I want some money
for a while before I get work I like I
mean those things don't work so I think
this grid is worth I gave this grid to
my to my radiologist doctor because I've
had some back problems and I wanted to
play golf and he gives me needles doing
steroids to try and get the back to calm
down so I gave him the page 257 and he's
got to let apron on and he's giving me
the shotty thing Jesus I gotta get out
of here I don't like any of these things
that I'm doing I don't like the people I
don't like the work you also have a
chapter on a subject that's very
important to a lot of our students and
that's work-life balance and you say
look you can get it but you have to earn
it
I think it's without question well bye
they're a company you want to be in a
family for a friendly company that's for
sure
but I do think the work/life balance
thing is not in a company brochure
that's a recruiting tool what it really
is it's an old-fashioned chit system you
over deliver you make your boss look
good you put chips in the bag when you
need flexibility where whether it be for
ballet or whether it for yo girl with a
B for kids or whether whatever whatever
it is you pull the chit's back out but
it is an old-fashioned chip system and
those that are stars and those that
deliver get flexibility and it's
something that is clearly earned and
it's not something that is handed to you
at the beginning of a game which we tell
this story in the book of this job where
a friend friends Boz was running a small
operation 60 people one of the women in
the job had a second child she had been
the company eight years she was a real
star she came in and said look I want to
work at home on Fridays and Mondays and
come in the office the three years a
week is that okay and they said
absolutely you've doing a great job
you're doing it fine and they want to do
it immediately
down the hall princess this young man
six months out of school and he says I'd
like to get Friday off and Monday off
and the boss said why he said I want to
practice perfect my yoga practice and
the boss she said no no way and he said
you mean to say you're making a
judgement and you're getting you're not
qualified I'll tell you that right now
to make a judgment between motherhood is
more valuable than my yoga practice you
have no right to do that and she said
I'm not making that judgment I'm making
the judgment you haven't earned a thing
in the six months you've been here
therefore you don't get the flexibility
you're barely doing your job now so
that's the way it's always going to be
it's you deliver you get flexibility you
don't do if every time your boss has a
report or need something desperately
wants to get it and you say I can't be
there things aren't going to go right
for you you've got to find the systems
that allow you to over deliver
and flexibility jack obviously you
learned about management by doing it I
mean you were a manager and you learned
about leadership by taking on a
management and leadership role but since
you've left that active life how much
just talking about it and going around
to places like this do you think if you
learn more by having to reflect on it
write books or not really Oh bother
I mean you this is a lot easier to
reflect back on as to how it works then
when you're doing it doing it it's a
bunch of chaotic steps it now looks neat
but I mean doing it or a series of
trials and our trials this is codifying
everything I know I think I learned more
in the last three years and I learned in
the first 40 at work just by
understanding what I did or what we did
how people responded what worked and
didn't work I mean when you're doing it
you're in the battlefield shrapnel is
coming from all sides
you're not thinking through a lot of
these moves I think hopefully this book
will give people some insights that can
be useful I mean I am a lot smarter
writing it today than I was when I
started so I'd say the I've learned a
hell of a lot now thank you very much
for being here again really appreciate
it a question that we've been debating
in the government of politics Club was
actually raised by Bala and the duds I
guess at Microsoft no don't overstate
that case I did they have a few guns in
the middle of all of Microsoft we won't
miss cloture just kidding so one of the
issues they recently pulled back their
support for this bill to for gay rights
I guess in the state of Washington and
so the question he raised and which I
like to hear your view on is how
involved or where do you draw the line
as a corporation in social policy and
what's your view on the involvement of
corporations in social policy that may
not directly relate to their business
per se you know my view and don't don't
forget I'm from a different
my view was clearly that you stayed out
of that that you didn't get involved in
government social policy and that GE
stayed 18 miles away from Madrid during
my time time man yeah I don't think it's
our business right our job is to be
competitive provide valued products and
services that create jobs and create an
environment where people can grow and
flourish that was our job and to be
non-discriminatory but not to go to jail
got you involve ourselves in government
policy regarding those things social
policy next yep Thanks so here at the
Business School we are given a lot of
models and a lot of ideas and we spent a
lot of time thinking and talking about
what we would do if we were in certain
situations or with certain information
one of the things that still bothers me
a bit that I'm hoping you can shed some
light on is when you're out working
it's my at least past experience that
you're overwhelmed with information that
it's not given to you in a you know
these are the three things you ought to
think about so pick a model to put it
into and if you can shed some light for
us on how you take maybe a thousand
pieces of information find the five that
are valuable to make a decision as a
manager and then then we can apply the
you know whatever model we have to those
five well I know who let me just start
out by saying the day you go to work
will be the last time you'll think about
a model I think okay
you will be involved in real-life
situations where you excuse me where
your pattern recognition will come into
play where where all of your experiences
will build and build and build to where
when you see something you'll act or
you'll say for example the real estate
boom is going like this and you'll drive
into a town and you'll see 50 cranes
everywhere and some Shahrukh it'll be in
not you but some of these five years
from now being pitching you on and one
more reels just one more building and
you'll say look I've seen this before
these things don't flow to the sky
this way over capacity now and there's
cranes as far as I can see that'll be
more valuable inside to you than any of
the models you study if they get out of
here we've done enough in this segment
in this cycle let's get them on the
downside when vacancies are high we can
buy in a third on the dollar and so
you'll give a whole series of life
experiences where your pattern
recognition will come into play you'll
meet people in the interviewing process
you'll do X percent the first three or
four four years of hiring you'll get
better and better you'll never get
perfect but you'll spot a phony better
you you understand that degrees mean one
thing but the day after they show up
degrees mean nothing it's really what
they can deliver so all these things
will come to you from that and I as far
as being over judged and did I never
found that to be a problem I always
found you know you're always short of
data you're really always short of
knowing the final answer that's why
you've got to go and you can't wait for
all the data I mean anybody could make a
decision in hindsight so you have to go
with your gut based on the experience
life experiences you have had to hire to
invest to fire all those things Thanks
we have a question over here dr. wulc
what is most important to you and why
you realize Jack that's a question we
ask all of our students that are
admitted what's most what matters most
to you and why but I think it changes in
time if I were here at this point in
time getting a job and pet and paying
off the loan be highly important okay at
my stage in life teaching learning and
money is not important so teaching and
learning is absolutely critical to me I
love the learning process
I love the being a better family person
than I ever was when I was working so
it's not to give back you I like you
giving back I teach principles in the
New York City school system I was never
going to go teach in the cities
principals in New York City and when
when I was in my day job and today I do
that I love doing it so I think things
change I don't think at any one moment
in time I think any one moment I'm you
can have the answer but as you go
forward hopefully things will change so
I don't have a particular thing now
other than learning and teaching and
giving back where's Derek shall we admit
him or not
I had a question around sort of the
ethical problems we've seen a lot of
corporate America and my question for a
senior executive like you is it is G's
ability to stay out of those problems
based on you know each executive
reflecting on what sort of decisions
they want to make before they become
into situations that could be gray zones
or is it more about setting up systems
around you in people around you to help
you make the right decisions
I clearly the lotta you couldn't have
350,000 people without systems and you
don't have the perfect 350,000 people
but you have Pro you don't see all lying
companies getting in fundamental trouble
because they've done everything wrong
over the last hundred years and there's
this isn't well when I joined GE the
first six months I was there I was
quizzed constantly about price-fixing
because GE had come up a price-fixing
case in the 50s so policies were in
place we'll never do a price fix I don't
think in the end where you've all been
trained we got 18 ways to catch it in
the 80s when when I was CEO and cap
Weinberger was going through the porn at
all a hammer in the in the toilet seat
that cost $600 etc and they had a big
fraud waste and abuse thing we had a
time cod mess and some guys were putting
projects on one thing then versus
another fraud project down the
organization and we had a fine and it
was a big scene we'll never have one of
those again I mean we may have one but I
won't get in each any size because we've
got 18,000 policies and quizzes and
tests to go through to solve them so
process is what happened if you go back
to the in Iran and the Arthur Andersen
cases this is a classic case of what can
go wrong in run a good pipeline company
got energy from point A to point B had
good processes in place but it was
boring
so they decide to go into trading and
they get the slicked-back
MBAs with the suspenders and the whole
program and they go out and stop trading
electrons for
tendency than electrons and everything
else and then and then broadband is that
tray but there was no culture to take
care of that there was no rules of the
road there was no processes Arthur
Anderson author innocent used to be
green eyeshade grunts for a hundred
years they were a great accounting firm
it was enough money in accounting so
they entered consulting in the 80s near
well familiar with what's now Accenture
but that was a piece of Arthur Andersen
when the consulting side they actually
ended up in croix in the 90s over
dividing the profits between the two
branches accounting and consulting now
when you gather that system in a company
how can you have values and processes to
control what was going on they were
chasing the money so breakdowns come
when massive cultural changes occur or
when there are no systems in place
because companies are started like
worldcom from a motel in Hattiesburg
Mississippi with men about a bunch of
small acquisitions no integration no
processes so the answer to a question is
clearly the latter point you may
companies have to test I mean in Jena
for example their online tests that
people have to pass to go to the BBB
before they can go to the next job it's
all about integrity and violations that
gray areas that might occur so companies
got spent a lot of time and rigor to
bring that out of the system we have a
big queue here let's work it down a
little bit next from the left-wing here
jack growing up as a kid the big thing
you heard about GE was GE we bring good
things to life since you've left the
mottos changed to GE
imagination at work I guess question to
you is what does that really mean and
how do you see that fitting in with the
direction of the company look I think
that they what they looked at was based
on my best understanding they looked at
we bring good think that thanks to life
and it looked like it was your father's
program and imagination at work
convinced some ADD kid that that was
more young youthful
so new new team new eyes new slogan
nothing wrong with that that's a view
that they have now going after that's
what change is all about and it's
supposed to be a more exciting
forward-looking image for the company
but that's you know we'll see what
really matters is is the company
delivering and they are now we've just
had a great quarter without a great year
and you know and I don't think whether
the slogan changes or not is that is
critical but I'm you know I'm totally
supportive of it
thank you you've referred several times
today to giving people rewards of the
wallet and rewards of the soul I'm
wondering if you could speak a bit about
how as a manager you thought about
motivating people by giving them the
right combination of rewards that would
work for them yep I would here's one of
the problems if you ask managers
tomorrow if you all went around in a
survey of middle managers and top
managers you were and you ask the
question do you celebrate enough you
would be shocked at how it was it no not
here we know that's all right you know
never happens one of the things you can
do as man when you go out is have small
celebrations for every little victory on
the way to reaching your vision excite
people give them better jobs send them
off to training do things for them that
aren't particularly right on the button
monetary but their recognition and you
got to do that but again plaques don't
substitute for cheques and so you've got
to have a combination of checks and
plaques and you can't and you can't
investment banking it's mainly cheques
but in most corporations people try and
get that balance right and recognition
awards patents all that stuff can be big
sow celebrations and I think that's the
job of the manager to make to come up
with that balance that feels right to
your team that turns them on
go ahead follow up how can you figure
out what's right for your team given
that each of us would have a different
answer to what matters most good because
I can't give you the concrete answer you
know your question just raise it each of
you will have a different view your job
is the sense that they remember the day
you become a leader it becomes about
them right it becomes about them your
job is to walk around with a can of
water in one hand and can't afford lies
in the other hand and think of your team
as seeds
and try and build a god now you'll end
up with some weeds and you have to cut
out some ways but that's your job it's
about building these people you know in
my case if they were dealing with me
didn't want to make me feel 6:4 with
hair and that's what you're going to try
and do you're going to try and do that
with your team and only you will know
the team some people be motivated by
this some of them are motivated by this
and you'll be the if you will the
orchestra conductor that will bring it
all together and I can't tell you what
mix of what is the right answer I know
one thing money comes it's important
it's an important part of the mix and
people get all caught up to munching the
plaque and the other stuff you can't
leave that out but I would air a little
on the on the monetary side of the
reward system
dr. Walsh I've admired your managerial
leadership for a long time so it's an
honor to have you here thank you when
you spoke about getting our the right
job for us that your first point which I
really love just to go somewhere where
we feel comfortable where people would
laugh at the same kinds of jokes that we
would my concern about that is that
research tells us that we feel most
comfortable around people who are
similar to us be it in gender or race or
nationality or so it's an economic
background how do we maintain comfort
but also push ourselves to places where
we can learn from a diverse environment
and
of learning from people who are
different than us it's a great question
I mean no but you wouldn't want to go to
a place where you couldn't be yourself I
don't think you want to reflect you
don't want to mirror any of everyone you
you look at looking like you I think you
do though want to be in a place we tell
a story in the in the book and I'll now
confess it Suzy we talk about this woman
who went to look for a job and she was
looking at consulting firms at the time
she's thinking getting her an MBA from
the other school on the East Coast and
she showed up at this place and she came
to this one place and the three people
waiting on top of the stands she walked
in and she fell and did a faceplant like
that and she said hi I'm Gracie the
ballerina
now the ballet teacher and the three
have looked at her like this you know
were you weird at the end of the day
they gave her an offer another
consulting firm gave her an office she
was much more comfortable going the
place that she didn't look with a front
with a line which I think it's funny and
she thought was funny hi I'm grace the
ballet teacher as she did a faceplant
and they were quite serious and stiff
about the whole event and it didn't feel
like a very good place to hang out both
consulting firms were great top three
and why not go in a place you want to be
I don't think it'd be emulates to do to
a personal style as much it's just
sensibilities if the sensibilities are
the same you if you're somebody that
likes to have fun relax a lot work like
hell but have fun doing it and you go
with a bunch of pompous stiffs that's
never going to be any fun for you and
they can be all different shapes and
colors that isn't the issue it's the
sensibilities with so much external
praise for your management style how do
you evaluate yourself and what failures
or shortcomings do you think you have in
your career and what have you done about
it yeah I was probably too quick
triggered early on I probably hired
people on some superficial
characteristics
you know good-looking and Stanford MBA
that's generally a pretty good package
and and that may or may not be any good
after a while okay
and so these are things that you learn I
I
at times in my career I thought I was
too big for my britches and I made some
bad acquisitions because I thought I
could buy anything it would all work out
I think you just you constantly reinvent
yourself you know what you were when you
the question that was first that's what
do you want to be yeah
it's going to change and you're going to
get smarter as you go along you're going
to learn so much you're going to laugh
at how little you know now five years
from now and that's the way you're going
to see it it's okay I know so much more
about how managers think and how they
feel and what frustrates them now than I
did when I was CEO so I think you're
going to constantly be learning and
evaluating making mistakes adapting your
style and people say well God is changed
oh thank thank God you've changed the
whole world's changed I mean if you
haven't if you don't change with you I'm
not saying change every day but you
certainly want to move from a learning
experience to a new platform and
behavior the dead that you picked up
because of experience you had mentioned
the importance of differentiation in in
a company that want that aims to be
successful and you made an analogy with
academic settings and it seems to me
that the difference is that if I choose
to be as as competitive and cutthroat as
I want in an academic setting the only
potential iLET it has for harm is that
it might hurt me because I don't build
relationships if I do that in a company
setting because I'm trying to get ahead
it undermines your value of you again if
you do that in the company that just got
any values you're dead you're more dead
there than you are in school in school
you can do it and get grades and take a
lousy personality and go out
in a company your peers will eat you
alive and spit you out that's what will
happen without behavior so the idea of
differentiation causing a lack of
teamwork it's the silliest anti argument
in the world and it's brought up all the
time how do you think teams win do you
think the Yankees pay the second baseman
the same as they pay Alex Rodriguez and
yet as a team they win the idea of a
high performers and low performers not
being able to work a medium form it's
not being able to work together if you
set the behaviors you want if you say
cutthroat behavior no sharing of ideas
is a killer in your culture you get you
won't get it if you allow it in your
culture you'll get it that's what about
the values you set the values and the
behaviors but now I'll let you pinch
your question as a manager how do you
keep track of who's doing what how do
you know which people are being
cutthroat and which people are just
doing the job you mean all of your own
people all of your own people you mean
ten people and you don't know yeah
that's your job
I mean that is fundamentally the job you
were gonna have if you've got a horse's
ass they're doing bad things and you got
to go on you'll just integrate your
whole team but that's why you're being
paid they gave you that job to figure
that out
no seriously I mean that's really what
your job is I don't mean to be
aggressive here but that's what's what's
your job
I hope you could share some insight into
how you manage your own time
particularly when you were heading a
large company I'm sure everybody wants a
piece of the CEO everybody wants to talk
with the Chairman no I know what my job
was I really understood that my job was
not managing to find a new comedy build
a jet engine a build a medical scanner
it was in it's an impossible job but I
knew my job was building people building
talent and I came to work every day
thinking about the people process and
thinking about evaluations when I went
to factories I sat down with the Union
and talked with them about how things
were going more to find out what the
atmosphere in the place was than to find
out the specific specific grief so my
job if we didn't build all these leaders
that now we have 35 or so for fortune
500 CEOs and for the Dow Jones 30 if we
didn't do that we would have failed
because my job was not coming up with a
Seinfeld comedy or apprentice show or
any of these things my job was to get
somebody to run that place who could
come up with those things so my time was
I'd say 65 to 75% on that I had three
things I had to do I had to pick people
I had to allocate resources based on
what the people were selling me
eyeball-to-eyeball and they had transfer
good ideas generic ideas across the
business that's all I did I didn't have
any pricing power any design issues any
of those things I knew my job and so I
allocated most of my time to people
Thanks
dr. Walsh um I have a question on the
appraisal system yeah um specifically
the grading curve we talked about and
you mentioned earlier that you spend a
lot of time just doing whatever to keep
the top 20%
the next the middle 70% you kind of tell
them how to get to be the top 20% and at
the bottom 10% you kind of help them out
but help them out as well what I
struggle with is that it seems to be a
zero-sum game the moment you put it in
relative terms the seventy middle 70%
cannot make it to the top 20% without
someone in the top 20% falling out into
the middle 70% in terms of the actual
application of this system is there is
it does it work because G is so large
because if you try to to implement it in
a small enough divisional unit you
actually may lose a lot of good people
but aren't you raising the bar all the
time yeah wait tell me a better system
to raise the bar of all of the group
give me an alternative this is one I've
got
that I think is the best I've come up
with I don't say it's the only one it's
one I believe is better now you tell me
a better one to get a better team all
right
what I'm what I'm uncomfortable with is
that the bottom 10% even if they happen
to in absolute terms we still be asking
me if it is it not that rigid in
practice oh it's not I mean you're not
down there with a fine-tooth comb this
is all directional but clearly you want
to get there you don't want to spend a
lot of them it's like having the the bad
egg on the plate would point round you
don't want to spend your time trying to
take somebody that's not very good and
you wanted me take great people and make
them unbelievably great that's what your
job is if you waste time trying to get
somebody over the bottom 10 threshold
you'll be spending a lot of energy on
something that's not very productive and
they can and they'll do fine elsewhere
if you do it early enough in their
careers so I just think it's the best
way to do it I I but I I would never sit
here and say this is the only way and
you can get embracing I don't like this
because after I do it twice I've already
gotten really rid of the weak people now
now I've got a perfect gene that's not
true because what will happen is you'll
get promoted cuz you have a great team
and if you don't keep doing it somebody
else is going to come into your job and
they're going to say well what is your
name what is your name right don't so
they're going to take John Don got
promoted he went to another place and
then they come to Dawn's job and they go
well and and they're going to look at
the people ok they're going to look at
the people and then I say and they're
going to do a top-20 middle 74 bottom 10
and they say my god how did he keep that
person so you're not doing anybody any
favors because fresh eyes will look at
it differently every time and so I just
think it's the best way to build a team
but I do not say it's the only way to
build the team I found it to be a clear
cut it forced evaluations it forced
people to stop winking at people it was
transparent and people knew they got a
fair shake one of the things that you'll
find a company somebody does a great job
as
let's give him something for doing that
great job you'll have this incredible
experience they'll say get me I was it I
can't I don't want to make be at the
others feel bad well if you can't
identify what they did and justify the
great thing they did by rewarding them
you shouldn't do it but if you can do it
you should do it and make it transparent
as can be it doesn't mean the others
can't get something someday for
something but this idea of leveling
everything it's like the companies that
give a hundred or five hundred stock
options to everyone it's the dumbest
game in town it's like having a dental
plan I mean what do you gain if
everybody gets it there's there's no
evaluation it's no differentiation
people people know who's whose can't get
carrying the freight and they know who
is not carrying the frame in our company
for example despite this system after
seven years the Trump people thought we
were tough enough on weak performance 90
plus percent of the blind surf survey
said we were as we went down in the
organization there was a massive
complaint that we weren't tough enough
on weak performance the people closest
to the work know who's pulling the deals
and the boat and so they're mad as hell
when somebody comes in two hours late
and they have to cover for them and do
this and that so the idea of being
rigorous is something that absolutely
increases the morale of a company it
does not decrease the morale of a
company no one likes a company or a unit
that carries a look just think of the
rowboat for on each side you are working
on one side what happens is the boat
goes run around in circles and everyone
in the organization knows who's carrying
the frame your job is to find out as
much as they know so I I like it it's
the best system of them found
we built great teams and the proof is
the enormous number of leaders that we
built from that system I don't see
another one I'm not another system
delivering that many leaders
I think that one of your parts of your
legacy would be what you left behind in
your successor can you shed a little
light on what went into your decision
when you went left with very capable
people at the end yeah it's back to the
question we got asked earlier got all
this data a feeling of smell a
confirmation by a board that took seven
years to come up with the answer a lot
of times seeing a lot of differences
situations we made a call we couldn't
have gone wrong on either one any one
one of the three couldn't have gone
wrong and we made a call the best about
our ability and so far he's making us
look very good but I don't have a
specific just to gut a field and so do
they have a gut in the field but the
other two I mean somebody is some other
group for determinate picketing any one
of the three we couldn't have lost under
any circumstance
because we spent all our time building
that day see the interesting thing is
that was our job these companies didn't
end up with no successes they got to go
outside they had failed in their
fundamental job the board's failed the
CEOs failed that's a big massive failure
getting your successor for the last six
years was the biggest thing in my mind
but there's no precise did he make a
deal Bob Nardelli who who was here
talking to you had by far the best
financial results in G by phone not by a
little bit by far and in here he still
has trouble he made him even said it
here he clearly does he still has
trouble in saying why not me yeah I had
the best numbers and I said well I can't
tell you one
thanks one more last question earlier
this year we heard from a three synergy
executives who had been very successful
in their career and from their
conversations with us it was clear that
they had to make some serious family
sacrifices along the way to get to where
they were and so while the opportunities
for maybe balance were there it didn't
appear that they took them up so I was
wondering from a leadership perspective
whether you think it's the
organization's responsibility to to deal
with that or whether it's more up to the
individual I think this is an individual
call Bob's balance my balance your
balance might not look like balance any
one of the others looking at it but I
think this is something that each person
has to come to grips with themselves I
don't think an organization can make a
balanced decision for you I just don't
think so I think you got to decide what
your priorities are what's important to
you and and be comfortable with those
priorities and this may be not
politically correct but the
organization's job is to win the
organization winning companies are the
only thing that count
losing is of no value to anybody if
winning companies pay taxes they give
back GE had 45,000 mentors teaching kids
in the NEC schools do you think those
dot-coms up yet had mentors they were
hanging on for dear life finally selling
the furniture okay they that does no
good for anyone so a company's job is to
provide opportunity give you fair
meritocracy and give you a chance your
job is to choose your lifestyle what you
want don't want how much of this you
want how much of that you want it is not
the company the share owners job to
figure out your balance that's something
you've got to do that may not be
politically correct
but that's the way it is and only
winning companies count and get all this
other stuff out of your mind if you got
any of it into it that that anything
other than winning counts in companies
because they give job security they give
poise that give back
they give satisfied lives people can
choose balance or not balance in those
companies but their job is to win and
create valued products and services that
allow the institution to go forward
remember companies are the only thing
that drive the society successful
companies government creates no revenues
they get it all from your taxes and
company's taxes and then they do good
things they defend us in war they have
judicial systems they educate us they do
all those things but they do it from no
income they only do it from successful
companies so successful companies are
the engine of the society government is
the support to that and they say and
that's why a company's job is delivering
winning products happy successful people
but they've gotta decide how much they
want to give here they're everywhere
Jack thanks so much for sharing your
time and your wisdom and insights the
book is winning there'll be a book
signing in Upper Arbuckle and the money
goes to charity that's right please join
me in thanking jack
yeah